-Donald Trump and his loyalists
in the Republican Party
are as laser-focused
as they ever have been
on subverting future elections
to regain power,
as they demonstrated
yet again
at another deranged rally
in Arizona over the weekend.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, today is
Martin Luther King Jr. Day,
which means it's a day
full of Republican politicians
who support
voter-suppression efforts
and have spent months fanning
a crazed right-wing panic
over so-called
critical race theory,
deceptively quoting Dr. King
out of context,
like the new governor
of Virginia, Glenn Youngkin,
who signed an executive order
banning the teaching
of critical race theory
on his first day in office
and then went on Fox News
and quoted Dr. King.
-We're not gonna
teach our children
to view everything
through a lens of race.
Yes, we will teach all history,
the good and the bad,
because we can't know
where we're going
unless we know
where we have come from.
But to actually
teach our children
that one group is advantaged,
and another is disadvantaged,
simply because of the color
of their skin,
cuts across everything
we know to be true.
And the immortal words
of Dr. Martin Luther King
ring in our ears
that we must judge one another
by the content of our character,
not the color of our skin.
-It's, like, the only MLK line
Republicans have ever read.
[ Laughter ]
It's like how
the only Chumbawamba song
anyone knows is "Tubthumping,"
even though they have tons more.
There's one where
they get knocked down
and don't get back up again.
It's super sad.
Played it
at my grandpa's funeral.
[ Laughter ]
See?
This is what happens
when you do a show
in an empty apartment
for a week.
[ Laughter ]
You forget how jokes go
when they're in a room
full of human beings with souls.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, anyway, Republicans
quote Dr. King
the way Trump confidently
dances to "YMCA,"
but doesn't seem
to know anything
about the Village People
or the context of the song.
-♪ Young man, are
you listening to me? ♪
♪ I said, young man,
what do you want to be? ♪
-"YMCA. We love the YMCA.
Don't we, folks?
And you know who else loves it?
The cop, the sailor, and
of course, the leather daddy.
Oh, they love -- they love
to go to the YMCA
and swim a few laps
before they go out on dates
with their wives
and girlfriends."
[ Laughter ]
And even when
they do try quoting
any other MLK line,
they apparently can't be
bothered to read any further
than the exact quote
they're looking for.
Today, for example,
Florida Senator Marco Rubio
tweeted this deceptively
quoted line from Dr. King's
"I Have a Dream" speech
without any additional context.
"When the architects
of our republic
wrote the magnificent words
of the Constitution
and the Declaration
of Independence,
they were signing
a promissory note
to which every American
was to fall heir."
Did you read
any further than that,
or did you just pull up
the text of the speech
and do a Control-F
for "things that make it sound
like he agrees with me"?
'Cause, dude, you got to read
just like two more lines,
and then you'll see that
the rest of the quote says,
"This note was a promise
that all men, yes, black men,
as well as white men,
would be guaranteed
the unalienable rights
of life, liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
It is obvious today
that America has defaulted
on this promissory note
insofar as are citizens of color
are concerned."
Man, it's times like these
that you just wish Rubio
would go back to his old job
as the picture
that comes with the frame.
[ Laughter ]
I know they're liars
and con artists,
but Dr. King was essentially
saying, "You made a promise
and you didn't keep it."
And Rubio just quoted
the "you made a promise" part.
That would be like quoting
"Since U Been Gone,"
but not the chorus.
[ Laughter ]
As Kelly Clarkson said,
"And all you'd ever hear me say
is how I picture me with you.
That's all you'd
ever hear me say."
Moving words about a love
that lasted forever.
[ Laughter ]
Of course,
all of these outrageous
bad-faith misrepresentations
of what Dr. King said
are happening
as Republicans led by Trump
are actively engaged
in attempts to suppress votes
and subvert future elections.
It's now been over a year
since Trump unleashed
a violent mob on the Capitol,
with rioters who waved, among
other things, Confederate flags.
And we know that not only
did Trump sic that mob
on the Capitol,
he gleefully watched them on TV
as they tried
to overthrow democracy.
And he refused
to do anything about it,
as even his closest allies
privately pleaded
with his chief of staff
to put a stop to the riot.
And yet Trump
is still walking around,
lumbering into arena rallies
in that oversize coat
and red hat like a mobster
who has to umpire
a Little League Baseball game
to fix the score.
"Strike 3. You're out."
"But that was the first pitch."
"He could get last, and
the only thing
you'll be sliding into
is the East River."
[ Laughter ]
Trump is still free, somehow,,
despite multiple
investigations into his business
and political activity,
including his attempt
to shake down
the Georgia secretary of state
to quote,
"find" enough votes
for him to win.
Now, I could cite any number
of legal experts
or constitutional scholars,
but, instead, I'd like
to highlight an esteemed voice
who I consider far more of
an authority on these issues.
That's right. Little Steven.
-What kind of country we live
in where the guy is not charged?
-We're living in an asylum.
Okay?
We're living in an insane asylum
right now.
Okay?
You know, if -- If you --
If you commit your crimes
in broad daylight,
uh, then it's okay.
I mean, I could make --
I could make a case right now,
you know, that we, you know,
that this guy is guilty of
treason 10 times over.
But he's on videotape saying,
"Go down,
overthrow the government."
The guy is a criminal
in the criminal empire.
And the more,
the bigger his crimes,
the more public they are,
the more he gets away with it.
And this is why Biden's
approval rating is so low.
Okay? It's because America
respects strength, you know,
and they'll even take it
from a phony buffoon,
you know, blowhard like --
like Trump, who's not strong,
but he pretends to be strong,
so they even go with that.
We got the biggest criminal
in the world
running around playing golf.
We can't even arrest him.
I love -- love --
listening to political opinions
in that accent.
It makes me feel like
I'm in a taxicab
begging the driver
to keep his eyes on the road.
[ Laughter ]
I'm surprised he didn't end
his rant with,
"So, uh, near corner
or far corner?"
[ Laughter ]
Honestly,
they should let Steven
prosecute the case
against Trump,
although they'd probably
just make him share a mic
with Merrick Garland.
[ Laughter ]
It's also remarkable how Trump
has driven everyone so insane,
they're becoming more and more
like their fictional characters.
Arnold Schwarzenegger brandished
his Conan sword,
De Niro's dropping F-bombs
like he's in "Goodfellas,"
and now Little Steven is saying
people respect strength,
like he's advising Tony on
what to do about Uncle Junior.
Next thing you know, Nic Cage
is gonna try to steal
the actual
Declaration of Independence.
"We have to protect it
from Donald Trump!
Go see, 'Pig!'"
[ Laughter ]
So, Trump is still walking free,
despite what you would think
is overwhelming evidence
of his guilt,
including the fact that he
fomented a violent insurrection
to overturn an election
that resulted last week
in seditious-conspiracy charges
against some of the key
militia figures involved.
-11 members of the far-right
anti-government
extremist group
the Oath Keepers
have been charged
with seditious conspiracy.
-The leader of the
far-right extremist group
the Oath Keepers is due
to appear in federal court.
Stewart Rhodes
is one of 11 defendants
who the Justice Department
charged with sedition
on Thursday for
their involvement
in the January 6th insurrection.
-These are the most
significant charges
in the investigation, so far.
-It's a sign of both
how dangerous
and how dumb our times are
that one of the key
violent groups
involved in an attempted coup
is called the Oath Keepers.
It sounds like the name a group
of 12-year-old
amateur detectives
would give themselves.
"We will solve the case
of the unreturned library books,
for we are the Oath Keepers.
[ Inhaling asthma medicine ]"
Oath Keepers sounds
like a "Yellowjackets" knock-off
about a group of teen girls
who have to keep
a terrible secret,
although I would definitely
watch a show
about a group of teen girls,
plus Donald Trump,
who had to keep a secret,
because it would be
only a half an episode
before he gave it up.
"What happened to you
in the woods?"
"We did what we had to do
to survive."
"We ate Claire.
We ate our friend Claire
to stay alive.
We did. We did. We ate her.
We could pretend we didn't,
but we ate her.
We ate her, and I do think it's
what Claire would have wanted,
even though her last words were,
'I don't want this!'"
[ Laughter ]
But as we've learned throughout
the entirety of the Trump era,
it's very possible
to be both dumb and dangerous
at the same time.
The indictment
from the Justice Department
is full of both dangerous and
also incredibly stupid details.
For example, at one point,
the accused Oath Keepers
were caught discussing
both bringing weapons
with them to the Capitol
and what uniforms
they should wear.
One said to another,
"Pack khaki/tan pants.
Weapons are OK now as well.
Sorry for the confusion.
We are packing the car
and heading your way shortly."
And then another replied,
"We don't have any khakis.
We have jeans."
They're a violent militia group
trying to overthrow democracy,
and they sound like waiters
getting ready for work.
"You can't wear jeans
at the Olive Garden!"
"But they're
my nice dark jeans!"
"Jeff, we've been through this!"
"I thought, when I was here,
I was family!"
"That slogan
is for customers, Jeff!"
[ Laughter ]
"You know that!"
And at another point,
these morons came up
with what they thought
was a foolproof plan
for escaping law enforcement.
According to the indictment,
one sent an email to another,
and attached to the email
was a photograph
that showed cursive handwriting
on a lined notepad that stated
"Secure Comms Test.
Good talk tonight, guys."
And they explain
the cursive writing
by adding, "Messages in cursive
to eliminate digital reads."
Oh, my God,
you absolutely dip[Bleep].
It doesn't matter
if it's in cursive.
You're attaching it
to an email.
It's like disguising your voice
during a bank robbery
while you stare directly
into the security camera.
"Listen to my voice.
You have three hours
to meet our --
Oh, was not a camera? [Bleep]
[Bleep], did you guys know
the bank had a camera?
It actually does matter, Jeff!"
[ Laughter ]
Did you genuinely think that
attaching a message in cursive
meant it was somehow secure?
Is that how you think
the US military communicates,
by passing handwritten notes
like teenagers in math class?
"Psst, psst, I have a message
from the Joint Chiefs of Staff
to seal Team Six.
He says, 'I think UR cool.
Do you want to raid
a compound l8ter?'"
[ Laughter ]
For some reason, these
insurrectionist morons
have the idea
that writing things on paper
makes them extra top secret.
For example, at Trump's rally
over the weekend,
MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
claimed he had invented
a new form of paper
for future elections
that was
somehow even more secure
than the paper we have now.
-We have a replacement
for the machines.
A matter of fact, tomorrow
we're going to film it.
The replacement? It's paper,
but it's paper on steroids.
It's the most awesome paper
you ever seen, with --
You can't copy it, OK?
It's better than money.
-What is paper on steroids?
"It's paper, but you don't need
a pen to write on it.
You can just use your finger,
and it responds to touch
and you can transmit it
to a secure central
processing server.
Oh, [Bleep] it's a computer.
I accidentally -- I accidentally
invented a computer.
Oh, this is more embarrassing
than when I thought
I invented the pillow."
[ Laughter ]
The coup attempt Trump and his
gang of authoritarian dopes
started shortly after
the November 2020 election
is ongoing.
It's just
a slow-moving coup now,
and they're trying
to pull it off
without too many people
noticing,
which is why we have to pass
urgently needed
voting and election reforms
and hold the people who staged
the insurrection responsible.
Otherwise, they'll do it again.
They'll try
to overthrow democracy
and shred the Constitution,
which, as the founders
themselves put it, is...
-The most awesome paper
you ever seen.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
God's Love We Deliver cooks
and brings over 2 million
meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and
other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.